irgendwas geht bei tesla vor die daten
des tesla trucks und des neuen roadsters
sind so unglaublich dass bei tesla im
geheimen eine absolut neuartigen
batterie und ladetechnik entwickelt
worden sein muss denn mit der bisherigen
technik ist das einfach nicht machbar
also wie ist die lage bei tesla jetzt
bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen immer wieder haben wir
hiervon neuen revolutionären
batterietechnologien berichtet höhere
kapazitäten schnelleres laden was da in
zukunft kommt ist wirklich bahnbrechend
wohlgemerkt in zukunft es wird noch
einige jahre dauern bis es wirklichkeit
werden kann
bei tesla scheint das jetzt aber schon
anders zu sein der tester truck und der
roadster haben so unglaubliche
technische daten das geht nicht ohne
eine neue batterie technologie schon der
russe hat absolut wahnsinnige
leistungswerte eine beschleunigung von 0
auf 100 in 1,9 sekunden ein porsche 918
spyder schafft es in 2,6 sekunden das
ist absolut state of the art und selbst
in der formel 1 gibt es kaum höhere
werte aber bei tesla im zwei jahren 2020
das wäre noch knapp mit aktueller
technologie zu erklären sogar 1000
kilometer reichweite wäre nun knapp
erklärbar mit einem tesla akku pack und
zwar dem größten mal zwei und die ersten
die im neuen tesla roadster saßen
berichten auch von einer erhöhten
sitzposition indiz für ein zweites pack
aber auch das ist noch nicht die lösung
noch ist da nämlich eigentlich zu wenig
platz unter dem motto stadt zitat dass
es heute physikalisch noch nicht möglich
das sagt elektroauto spezialist saale
morsey von bloomberg new energy finance
aber was der neue trakt aber leisten
soll das ist der absolute ganze wahnwitz
ein 40 tonner mit 800 kilometern
reichweite in 30 minuten sondern energie
für weitere 600 kilometer nach laden
können wie bitte und der
produktionsbeginn soll 2019 sein also in
einem jahr
das ist wirklich unglaublich und das im
wahrsten sinne des wortes da staunt der
laie und der fachmann wundert sich
tatsächlich kann sich niemand diese
leistung erklären der neue mega charger
mit zehn mal stärker sein als der
bisherige super charger zitat
ich verstehe nicht wie das funktioniert
sagt salim sie das tue ich wirklich
nicht der experte von bloomberg new
energy finance ist wirklich überfragt
dort schätzt man dass der tesla semi
eine batteriekapazität von 600 bis 1000
kilowattstunden haben muss das ist
zehnmal mehr als die größte batterie für
den tesla es im maximalfall mit der
heutigen batterietechnik würde ein
solches battery pack 5 tonnen wiegen und
mehr als 100.000 dollar kosten der see
soll aber nur abhängig von der größe des
packs 150 bis 180 tausend dollar kosten
diesel lkw kosten nur rund 120000 dollar
blumberg sagt dass diese daten nicht den
aktuellen industriestandards entsprechen
viele sind der meinung dass das nur mit
einem bisher geheimen fortschritt in der
batterietechnologie möglich ist santa fe
batterie experte bei köln energy
research dazu ich glaube nicht dass sie
lügen
ich denke dass sie etwas bei der
vorstellung ausgelassen haben was
erklärt hätte wie sie auf diese zahlen
gekommen sind trotzdem muss man nach der
produktionshalle beim modell 3 wo viel
weniger fahrzeuge produziert werden als
angekündigt wurden vorsichtig seien zwar
scheint man bei tesla langsam die
stückzahlen erhöhen zu können in der
letzten dezemberwoche wurden 793 model 3
produziert aber hier wurde viel mehr
versprochen als dann letztlich möglich
war es bleibt also spannend bei tesla
wenn nämlich wirklich diese
leistungsdaten bei den neuen fahrzeugen
erreicht werden könnten dann stehen wir
wirklich vor einem quantensprung beim
elektroantrieb ab 2019 könnten dann
tagesreichweiten von pkw mit
verbrennungsmotor erreicht werden die
schallmauer wäre durchbrochen und damit
stünde auch das elektroauto vor dem
endgültigen durchbruch wenn ihr mit die
ersten sein wollen die von den aktuellen
entwicklungen erfahren dann wird mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen ich
den genau auf die glocke und dann werdet
ihr auch über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken bald nur noch elektroautos
technik vor technologiesprung da geht es
genau um die weiterentwicklung der
batterietechnologie ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran